generally movies are pretty harmless
forms of escapist entertainment but
every so often a film will get its hooks
into reality and completely screw over a
living breathing person a movie can ruin
an actor's or filmmakers career or in
extreme cases caused the death of people
not even involved with the film the
following movies touch some very real
lives and things didn't end well for
anyone involved Snow White and the Seven
Dwarfs as it was one of the first
animated feature films ever made
you'd think Snow White and the Seven
Dwarfs would have turned it's leading
lady adriana caselotti into a major star
after all the film was a big hit and a
cinematic landmark but despite playing
and one of the most beloved movies ever
made caselotti largely vanished from the
Tinseltown scene after working on the
Disney film according to some theories
Walt Disney refused to let Casa Lotte
use her voice in any other program
keeping her under a tight contract so
that no one would know the secret voice
behind the princess however Disney
didn't start contracting actors until
1946 so that theory is unlikely instead
it seems that castle oddities own talent
betrayed her Disney himself said that he
couldn't cast her again because her
voice was just too easy to identify
while still refusing to let her work
elsewhere add that to the fact that she
was never credited on the original film
until it was too late and casalotti was
left with the slumbering career
peeping-tom once upon a time Michael
Powell directed some of the greatest
films of English cinema including black
narcissus and the red shoes but
everything changed in 1960 when panel
directed peeping tom
a wild departure from his previous work
peeping tom focuses on a shy repressed
young photographer who gets his kicks by
murdering women with a blade attached to
his camera tripod while tame by today's
standards audiences at the time were
absolutely shocked peeping tom deals
with all kinds of uncomfortable topics
from child abuse to pornography British
critics lost their minds labeling the
film is perverted and beastly Powell was
exiled from the British film industry
and could only make movies in other
countries
none of which lived up to his old
classics as a result the man in his
movie faded into obscurity until 1979
when Martin Scorsese re-released the
film these days peeping tom is
considered one of Powell's best films
and the British Film Institute labeled
it the 78th greatest British film ever
but there's no denying this 1960 flick
completely killed pals career LeMond
Steve McQueen wanted to make the
greatest racing movie ever unfortunately
things didn't pan out the way McQueen
had hoped when he was filming LeMond the
film's original director John Sturges
had his own vision for the film and
eventually left the project over
creative differences by the end the
movie had gone so far over budget that
McQueen was forced to give up a salary
and the making of LeMond would
ultimately cause his company cellar
productions to collapse but at the end
of the day at least McQueen made it out
of Lomond in one piece
the same can't be said for David Piper a
Formula one racer working on the film
Piper was driving of course 917 for a
scene and lost control of the car
severely injuring his leg the wound
became infected and doctors were forced
to partially amputate his film about
Lamoille
the injury effectively ended his racing
career and it was all for a movie that's
largely been forgotten by most
moviegoers the message in 1977 director
of Moustafa akkad released the message a
desert epic in the vein of Lawrence of
Arabia only instead of focusing on an
English adventurer the film tells the
story of the Prophet Muhammad and the
rise of Islam true you're not supposed
to actually depict Muhammad but Akkad
got around this by having actors speak
directly at the audience as if the
camera itself was the Prophet but
despite the Qods attempts at making a
peaceful inoffensive film quite a few
people took his message the wrong way
several countries banned the film but
even worse someone decided the stage of
protest with swords and shotguns Hamas
Abdullah kalise and a group of eleven
took over multiple buildings in
Washington DC and claimed 149 hostages
tragically this attack wasn't without
casualties
when the group stormed the district
building Kelis and his group shot and
murdered security guard matt cantrell
and a reporter named Maurice Williams
fortunately the rest of the hostages
were freed 39 hours later and Calais was
sentenced to life in prison where he
died in 2003 The Goonies
it's safe to say that the people who
love the Goonies really really love it
in fact fans from as far away as Europe
have made the pilgrimage to Astoria
Oregon to see the Goonies house for
themselves you know the one it's two
storeys tall has cool stuff in the Attic
and you have to do the truffle shuffle
to get inside but while the Astoria
house has brought joy to a lot of fans
not everyone is so happy with the homes
popularity sandy Preston bought the
house in 2001 and at first she was
totally cool with fans showing up to
take photos however all that changed in
2015 when she wrapped her house with
blue tarps and set outside saying her
home was now off-limits to the public so
what prompted such a radical change in
recent years the amount of tourists
coming to see the house was on the rise
shockingly during the summer of 2015 up
to 1500 people dropped by her home every
single day while some were on their best
behavior many of these fans didn't care
all that much about manners people show
up before dawn or well after dark
leaving beer bottles cigarette butts and
we'll say presents from their pets
eventually it was all just too much for
Preston who decided it was time to take
her house back thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to her
youtube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to
[Music]